président russe Vladimir Poutine et le
président turc Recep ta hyper douanes
ont entamé des discussions depuis hier à
Astana au Kazakhstan à l'occasion d'un
forum régional plusieurs points sont
alors du jour la proposition d'un plan
de paix élaboré par le président turc
pour mettre un terme à la guerre en
Ukraine autre dossier la poursuite du
développement des relations économiques
entre la Russie et la Turquie Armelle
charrier les Turcs proposent leur
médiation peut-elle fonctionner sur quoi
peut-être déboucher en tout cas elle
peut fonctionner la médiation
turque aujourd'hui parce que d'abord à
la fonctionner une précédente fois quand
il y avait les problèmes sur les
céréales qu'il fallait extraire de la
mer Noire et qu'il fallait renvoyer vers
d'autres pays et ensuite parce qu'on est
dans un moment où les gens se parlent
quasiment pas et que donc du coup le
président turc qui est à la fois
vieille-aillé de Vladimir Poutine les
deux se connaissent très bien ils ont à
la fois des contes à rendre la Turquie
en règle générale elle doit plutôt des
choses à la Russie que l'inverse mais
donc du coup là il est quand même dans
une position il faut négocier avec
Vladimir Poutine il est aussi suivi par
les Occidentaux parce qu'il représente
l'OTAN et que donc dans ces conditions
il parle aussi de l'autre côté c'est pas
je vais dire l'interlocuteur idéal mais
il s'est il a eu cette intelligence de
réagir rapidement de voir que il est
capable de vendre des armes à l'Ukraine
quand ils vendaient des drones
maintenant un peu moins quand même mais
en même temps aussi de converser avec la
Turquie et donc de dire moi je
représente un canal et que il faut
mettre ce canal par exemple au
Kazakhstan qui lui aussi est un pays
concerné donc on est avec une
gymnastique de pays qui ne reconnaissent
pas l'annexion des territoires par en
Ukraine de Vladimir Poutine mais qu'ils
mettent pas en place non plus les
sanctions donc ils sont un peu plus
libres de parole et quel est le jeu du
coup de Red job ta hyperdoine mais aussi
de Vladimir Poutine alors ils ont tous
les deux des choses à gagner évidemment
j'allais dire en affichage et aussi
beaucoup économiquement
le président turc il a saisi cette
opportunité parce qu'il est bon erdoine
sur la capacité de saisir les
opportunités derrière il a une économie
qui s'effondre il a 80 % d'inflation
donc concrètement pour les Turcs ça veut
dire que ils peuvent même pas t'acheter
une botte de radis il a failli ils
doivent choisir entre la salade et du
radis et ce sont même plus acheter de la
viande 80 % d'inflation on imagine ce
que c'est nous on en a 6 % en France
donc lui derrière il a besoin de
commercer avec la Russie il le fait
aujourd'hui plus de 80% et donc du coup
il a besoin de gaz et il a besoin de
pétrole russe de l'autre côté Vladimir
Poutine il a besoin d'avoir quelqu'un
qui le laisse passer son gaz et son
pétrole donc ce qu'a proposé Vladimir
Poutine le fameux hub gazé pour être
treillé c'est de dire puisque je ne peux
plus sortir tout ça pendant stream soit
je le sors par l'Ukraine ce qui est
impossible soit il faut que je passe
sous la mer Noire et que donc du coup
j'arrive en Turquie et que le upgazié se
fasse du côté de la Turquie donc ça
évidemment pour Vladimir Poutine c'est
intéressant parce qu'il dit moi dans ce
cas là je vous intérêts aux Européens du
gaz qui restera moins cher le problème
c'est que côté occidental le
raidissement est immédiat le président
Macron par exemple pour prendre exemple
français a dit non nous avant n'importe
quel 40 % de pétrole russe aujourd'hui
on en apporte 7 et demi pour cent on
veut continuer dans cette descente et on
ne veut pas prendre du pétrole russe
cela dit les pays européens on le voit
sont laminés aussi par ce qui est en
train de se passer on voit que tous les
prix d'électricité etc flambe partout il
y a une inquiétude donc on verra aussi
qu'elle réalise mais quelle réalité il y
a derrière dernière chose on est là sur
les négociations économique diplomatique
on est quand même pas sur un rapport de
force en ce moment sur le terrain qui
favorise vraiment d'aller vers à un
moment donné de trouver une solution
mais en tout cas on plante déjà merci
beaucoup Armelle charrier pour votre
analyse merci à vous